well the most powerful position in cuba
is about to have a brand new face raul
castro recently announced he is stepping
down from controlling
the communist party claiming he has
fulfilled his mission
and is confident in the future of the
country the 89 year old
and his brother fidel have held the
power since 1959 since that revolution
cuban president miguel diaz-canel is
expected to replace castro
local residents from the island are
doubtful for major change
nothing going to change in cuba with
another administration more because it's
the same
people it's the same government it's the
same
school is everything about that system
maybe we have in the future in cuba
another
party another part of to try to change
that
maybe the young people like me stay
there they never gonna leave
cuba they start to think better and do
better job that business owner says he
left the country
and his family back in 2013 after not
being able to prosper
today he is thriving right here in las
vegas with his own restaurant and other
businesses
a dream he says he would have
established in cuba